hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game from the final round of
the 2018 World Chess Championship for
juniors of course you've already seen
that one run before the tournament ended
Parham actually won the world junior
championship 2018 but here we have a
game from the final round it's a Russian
International Master Sergey lobanov
versus an international master from
Norway
Johann Sebastian Kristensen it's a very
interesting game a lot of you have
requested me to show it so here it is
and we didn't have a photo challenge in
quite a while so best of luck best of
luck to everyone who is the gentleman in
the photo here here you have it like I
said best of luck to everyone now let's
check out this very nice game and I
didn't decide to show it just because
it's against the French defence efore e6
b4 and b5 so we we have the French
defense on the board Knight to c3 and
the knight to f6 at the classical
variation we have E 5 kicking away the
night this is their style its variation
advancing the pawn Knight after Lee 7f 4
C 5 and the Knight to f3
we have Knight to c6 and the Bishop to
e3 Bishop to e7 Queen to d2 and now a6
so all pretty standard here and here we
have D captures on c5 this is one of the
moves that very often bothered me when I
was playing against the French because I
always liked my pawn center here I never
want to capture away from the center but
you know sometimes you will not you will
have to do this because I don't know if
you decide to castle too early and then
black can even push c4 close your lights
we're a bishop in and then just simply
start pushing his own pawn
so after a6 we have d captures on c5
Knight captures on c5 and now comes a
queenside castle sorry about that
Queen to a5 by black and here King to b1
always a useful move so whenever this
Knight moves Queen captures and a2 will
not be a liability
black continues would be 5 and here we
have a very nice position black already
started his attack on the Queen side and
white has to decide what to do here you
could start by
something like g4 and then black will go
something like B for a kick away or
night and then the knife to e2 is
already already a nice move but then you
you have ideas like nice to a4 followed
by Knight to c3
perhaps ideas like this will be possible
in the future so white doesn't go for
the for such an early attack on the
Kings side
so after b5 we have night the d4
offering a trade of Knights special to
b7 black develops a piece h4 and now
rook to c8 black again develops a piece
on the C file h5 and here we have Queen
to c7 black well Queen c7 black decides
to bring the Queen back he thinks that
the whites attack on the on the Kings
side will be overwhelming most likely
but night chapters on d4 is also a very
nice idea after Bishop captures then B
492 and now comes the knife to e4 with
an attack on whites Queen Queen to e3
and now cling to a for attacking the c2
pawn with the Queen and the rook but
here after rook to c1 white would defend
but still it's a very nice position for
black so this was one way to go about it
after h5 we have Queen to c5 Queen to c7
Knight to c6 capturing we have Bishop
captures on c6 and now comes Knight to
e2 Knight comes to e4 and now comes
Queen to e1 as it was attacked on d2
better back to b7 here black is already
threatening to capture on c2 so white
has to prevent this night to DeForest
played we have Bishop to c5 and now
comes Bishop to d3 now capturing undie
for isn't all that impressive because
now the bishop also guards the C to pawn
we have castles by black and the now
comes Knight to f3 offering a trade of
bishops Queen to b6 and now comes Bishop
captures and here you don't really have
the option of playing something like
rook captures with the idea of doubling
on the C file because White has this
very nice h6 move and after g6 we are
sorry about that
after g6 Queen to h4 and now
capturing the night followed by Queen f6
the g7 checkmate will be a pretty big
threat and here f5 is playable of course
but then you run into e captures on f6
Knight captures and Bishop captures here
you can capture h7 check King h8 and now
after Knight to e5 it will be it will be
impossible to deal with all the threats
here so after Bishop captures on c5 we
have Queen captures on c5 and a now
comes h6 g6 and the now comes Queen to
h4 so pretty much a similar idea but it
will be a bit different
f5 was played in the game and now comes
ill captures on f6 but now of course
black will not recap for immediately but
first DeForest played d4 with the idea
that if now the knight is removed for
example Bishop captures then Bishop
captures now comes with a triple attack
against the c2 pond and also the bishop
will be guarding the g6 pawn nicely also
f5 will no longer be such a huge issue
but first white played instead of this
Knight to e5 and it's a very nice move
black now will have huge problems
pairing all the threats this is why I
use this quote above the board the great
master places a night at e5 checkmate
follows by itself so let's see how the
game have continued here if you played
something like rook to c7 perhaps that
try and cover the seventh rank you get
f7 with check King moves and now Bishop
captures simply remove the defender of
the f6 Square and here for example Queen
to f6 would be checkmate so we have
Knight captures on f6 but here comes the
bishop captures on g6 which was the idea
all along and you don't have the option
of capturing the bishop if you capture
it then you get h7 whoops check out King
g7 Queen to h6 King has to go back and
the now Knight captures an g6 will be
checkmate so after Bishop captures on g6
Queen back to e7 now and the Queen is
now coming back to help out with the
defense
Bishop back to d3 now the Kings the
King's defenses have been breached and
the bishop can now go back King to h8
and now comes
h2g one Sergey is not ready to push the
Jeep on also a very nice Vidya was f5
and after you capture you bring another
rook to e1 also a very nice way to bring
another attacker into into the game so
after King to h8 we have rook H 2 G 1
Queen to c7 and the now comes G 3 we
have Knight to d5 if you try something
like Bishop to g4 to eliminate some of
the some of the attackers and also a
defender of the c2 pawn it's not really
an issue simply Bishop captures Knight
captures and Queen to h2 temporarily
bringing the Queen back from the attack
but then the G pawn is coming definitely
so g3 nights the d5 was played Andrew
now comes rook to d2 introducing another
defender of the c2 pawn
Queen to a5 attacking the rook on d2 and
now rook to e2 and here comes rook to c7
if you tried something like nice -
before it's not really not really an
issue simply a three Knight captures for
example on d3 but now white will not
even bother recapturing simply Queen to
e7 and how do you stop Queen g7 you can
try something like Queen Queen to c7 but
then Knight to d7 and again you can't
prevent this you can either give up the
Queen or for example Ruby g8 and then
Queen f6 check roadblocks and Queen
again delivers checkmate
so after rook - E - we have rook to c7
perhaps with ideas of defending the
seventh rank and now comes f5 also a
very nice move
and now Queen to b4 capturing on f5 the
runs into queen captors on d4 that was
the idea of f5 making room for the Queen
so the Queen can capture and are all
sorts of nasty discoveries will be
possible here black doesn't want to face
these so Queen to b4 we have a three
Knight to g6 was possible right away but
you know you can never be too safe in a
chess game so a three with an attack on
the Queen and now Knight to c3 with
check of course you cannot capture this
because the the be pawn is pinned
this comes with a fork against the king
and the rook King to a-1 and what do you
play here if you try something like
Queen to e7 to trade Queens which seems
like a reasonable thing to do as you're
getting attacked you're gonna run into
Queen captures on d4 with some
discoveries Queen to f6 and now rook to
f2 what you play here doesn't really
matter
your knight is still under attack on c3
you have to move it now comes pawn
captures your queen is under attack
whatever you do pretty much loses here
but let's just show one nice line there
you have it an ID g 6 will be checkmate
as it's a discovered attack from the
Queen so it's a double check but in this
case checkmate King to a-1
now comes the Queen to d6 also guarding
the d4 pawn now we have Knight to g6
with check and again a very nice move if
you move the King you have there's
really no good move here if you move the
King you get Knight captures on f8 and
it's not that you're you watch the
exchange you're your king is simply to
open Queen captures now rook captures
here whatever you play or night is still
under attack and c3 you have to move it
95 now comes Queen g5 check King moves
and now rubgy to e1 and there are simply
too many threats here so after 96 H
captures on g6 was played we have F
captures on g6 and now you can see that
this is and this is some serious serious
problems for black King to g8 I'm not
allowing this check this check to happen
we have g7 now attacking the rook and
now Knight captures rook here it doesn't
really make sense to move the rook for
example rook to f3 simply h7 King
captures h8 with Queen King to f7 and
then Queen will deliver checkmate on h7
but pretty much when you see pawns
advanced all the way to here you know
that it's a game over but ok Knight
captures Donnie - was played and here
why they decided to go Queen to g5 now
h7 when h7 will be played the king will
no longer be able to capture the g7 pawn
Knight captures on g1 and here black
much decided he will not resign this
game so white could have ended it
immediately with Queen to g6 there's no
defense against Queen to h7 checkmate
the bishop is guarding the score but
okay you can temporarily give up the
rook for four for prolonging it for a
couple of moves but it's pretty much
pointless but as black didn't want to
resign a white decided to play our
little joke
he played h7 would check we have King to
f7 and now g8 this comes with two queens
on the board now and black doesn't even
bother capturing because that leads to a
mate in one after H captures here this
will be checkmate so black tried King to
e8 but now comes h8 with another Queen
and now we have this position where
White has three Queens on the board and
it was in this position that Johan
Sebastian Christians and international
master from Norway resigned the game why
did he resign well there are there are
three Queens on the board it's pretty
much self-explanatory but definitely a
nice game and especially since it was
the last round of the 2018 World Junior
Championship and this is a victory for
Sergei lobanov
I want him third place with eight and a
half points in this you know great
tournament still Parham axel was a whole
point up ahead of everyone else but
still a wonderful result and big
congratulations to him what a what a
great way to win third place in world
junior championship with three three
Queens on the board so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and I would like
to thank Johan Aleph Edlin Abdul to see
Alexander rode each P etter loss and
Tony Clements for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here and for today's game at
request you have the the the Nakamura
challenge so you have to you have to
finish the game with six nights on the
board but six nights of your own color
so if you're playing white you have to
have six white nights at the end of the
game if you're playing black you have to
have six
nights as you know that's pretty much
reasonable so it might be a bit more
difficult you know since your opponent
might resign but hey it's still a nice
nice thing to achieve
so best best of luck to a room with the
photo challenge and best of luck to
everyone with the Argonaut request I
hope you enjoyed this game and yeah like
I said as usual you can check - on my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and hopefully see you soon with
some more interesting content thank you